what you need is a good laugh maybe a
circus that's right let's get back to
Lauren and gritty who has magically
reappeared up at Craig Ranch Park to
profile Cirque Italia Lauren good
morning to you
good morning here we go round two here
yes sir katalia first traveling water
circus I've got Marjorie Rosenthal with
me spokesperson Marjorie okay what can
people look forward to yes so we are a
pirate Adventure Show and it's so
amazing here and we have this amazing
Dynamic watersheds behind us right now
with the splash high energy acts here
you're going to see acrobat we have so
many acrobatic skates as well and the
show is two hours long with the
intermission included thank you and have
people find tickets tickets are
available online at circuitalia.com you
can also book them at the onsite ticket
office and they are open daily from 10
a.m through 9pm thank you so much and if
you missed them this week they'll be
here through Monday they'll be at
Meadows mall next week for now in North
Las Vegas Lauren negretti 8 News Now